let me begin tonight with the latest
figures four million and forty three
thousand six hundred and eighty six
tests have been carried out in the UK
including one hundred and thirty one
thousand four hundred and fifty eight
tests yesterday two hundred and seventy
one thousand two hundred and twenty two
people have tested positive an increase
of two thousand and ninety five cases
since yesterday
sadly of those who tested positive for
coronavirus across all settings
thirty-eight thousand 161 people have
now died that's an increase of 324
fatalities since yesterday our thoughts
as always are with the family and
friends of those who have lost their
lives today's figures confirm what the
Prime Minister has said we are past the
peak we're flattening the curve we
protected the NHS and the number of
deaths is falling over the coming weeks
we can now take careful but deliberate
steps to reopen our economy across the
country office lights will be turned on
and windows thrown open workloads in
school uniforms will be pulled out of
the wardrobe shops and factories will
start to hum with activity as we enter
this new phase things will change
businesses will need to become covert
secure to protect staff and customers we
will all need to stay alert as we go
about our daily lives and as Britain
returns to work we need to adapt the
emergency programs we put in place to
bridge through the crisis because of
those programs and our economic
prospects are better than the otherwise
would have been we have provided tens of
billions of pounds of tax cuts tax
deferrals cash grants and discounted
loans for businesses income protection
for millions of the self-employed a
strengthened safety net to protect
millions of our most vulnerable people
and our job retention scheme has now
supported more than a million jobs and
over a million businesses
no British government labor or
conservative has ever done anything like
this I believe it has made a real
difference but as we reopen the economy
there is broad consensus across the
political and economic spectrum the
thorough scheme cannot continue
indefinitely two weeks ago I outlined
the principles of my approach the
furlough scheme will remain open all the
way until October we will ask employers
to start contributing as we also
introduce flexible furloughing and
employees will see no change to their
level of support as promised I can
provide more details today I believe it
is right in the final phase of this
eight-month scheme to ask employers to
contribute alongside the taxpayer
towards the wages of their staff but I
understand too that businesses and
employers have been through an
incredibly difficult time so I have
decided to ask employers to pay only a
modest contribution introduced slowly
over the coming months in June and July
the scheme will continue as before with
no employer contribution at all
in August the taxpayer contribution to
people's wages will stay at 80 percent
employers will only be asked to pay
national insurance and employer pension
contributions which for the average
claim account for just five percent of
total employment costs by September
employers will have had the opportunity
to make any necessary changes to their
workplaces and business practices only
then in the final two months of this
eight-month scheme will we ask employers
to start paying towards people's wages
in September taxpayers will pay 70% of
the furlough Grant with employers
contribution 10% in October
taxpayers will pay 60% and employers
will contribute 20% then after 8 months
of this extraordinary intervention
if the government's stepping in to help
pay people's wages the scheme will close
the biggest request I've heard from
businesses large and small right across
our country is to have the flexibility
to decide what is right for them so to
protect jobs and help businesses decide
how quickly to bring their workforce
back we are introducing a new more
flexible furlough this is a critical
part of our plan to kick-start the
economy the financial security of the
furlough scheme has been a relief for
many but at the same time people want to
work no one wants to be at home on
furlough no one wants to feel unable to
contribute so HMRC and the Treasury have
worked hard to put the flexible furlough
in place not from August the first is
originally planned but from July the
first one month early from July the
first employers will have the maximum
possible flexibility to decide on the
right arrangements for them and their
furlough staff for instance if you are
watching at home and on furlough your
employer could bring you back two days a
week they would pay you for those two
days as normal while the furlough scheme
would continue to cover you for the
other three working days to allow us to
introduce this new flexible furlough
from July the first we will need to
close the old scheme to new entrance on
June the 30th employers wanting to place
new employees on the scheme will need to
do this by June the 10th to allow them
time to complete the minimum furlough
period before then